the boy next door is directed by Rob
Cohen and stars Jennifer Lopez as an
English teacher who focuses on classical
literature wrap your mind around that
one because you're just gonna have to
get used to it in this movie her
marriage is going through some problems
she has a son who's like the sweetest
kindest most fake teenager I've ever
seen and a boy who moves in next door
who's like yeah I'm almost twenty like
they make a huge point to be like hey
this isn't creepy because he's almost 20
did you hear us he's he's almost 20 just
want to make sure you knew that and they
have sex because Jennifer Lopez is
attractive and he's attractive and they
they're like hey we're both attractive
so let's have sex
whoops he's a psychopath he starts
stalking her everywhere writing graffiti
sending her photographs all kinds of
stuff he's crazy and she has to figure
out how to save her marriage her family
her job everything and this movie is
terrible I mean did you really expect me
to say you know the boy next door isn't
okay movie not only is this January the
Hollywood garbage dump for film but I
strechted by rob coen maker of stealth
and Alex Cross and I alluded to it
earlier but I gotta bring it up they're
casting in this movie what Jennifer
Lopez is an English teacher teaching
classical literature and the vice
principal of the school is played by
Kristin Chenoweth
really it's all a gigantic pile of
Hollywood cliches that you just you
can't stand watching it and you can just
tell that no one in the movie is really
playing a character they're all just
trying to look really good for the
camera it's one of those movies where
you watch it you're like I guarantee
there are like professional people like
eyeing every single shot to make sure
that Jennifer Lopez looks beautiful and
wonderful and everything it's just I
can't stand movies like this guys I
can't it's so poorly acted it's so
laughably written it is filled with so
many plot inconsistencies and it's the
kind of film that when it ends there are
like at least two or three arcs that
have yet to be completed but the film
just thinks while everyone's done now so
we'll just have the end credits play no
there's like a ton more story things
they're left hanging that are unresolved
in this movie but they set up all of
these various arcs and they never have a
completion to it it's just like they
have all these scenes to lengthen the
runtime to get into a feature length
where they set up story plot points that
are never resolved I didn't care though
because I was like thank goodness and I
left but then I was reading the IMDB
trivia and apparently the film was made
in 25 days on a budget of 4 million
dollars so it really just seems like Rob
Cohen and the writer was just like
coming up really fast like how do we
make this like what should we do oh man
we're running out of time and money
let's just end it right here and of
course it's gonna make a profit because
Jennifer Lopez I mean any movie she's
going to be in is more than likely going
to open at more than 4 million just
because she's Jennifer Lopez this is a
thing in studios now guys ok pay
attention please
to box-office stuff I've been told
sometimes I pay attention too much to
that but you got to realize this is what
the studios are doing to us they're
making movies for like nothing that they
know will make a profit simply because
of maybe one star or one particular time
period the film's release like the first
weekend the Halloween or something and
they want to make a profit you want to
steal our money they want to make a
crappy movie and it's terrible don't see
it it's bad I'm gonna give the boy next
door and F it's awful it was hilariously
bad but not an entertaining way he just
got to a point where I had to force
myself to be entertained in some way so
that I wouldn't feel like walking out
and so I just started laughing at
everything I'm sorry I was laughing it
was funny it was dumb I hate it that
being said I am very excited to mention
that I do have a new segment coming up
called retro rewind in which I talk
about something from my past that has
had an impact on me in some way I'm
really excited to bring it to you
because I'm gonna have some awesome
celebrity guest appearances that I'm
really really psyched about I can't even
believe I was just like nerding out as
soon as they agreed to take part in it
my first episode is entirely about
Toonami which is the programming block
that popularized anime on Cartoon
Network in the late 90s in America and I
can't wait to talk to you guys about it
I'm super excited about it and I hope
you guys enjoy the episode I'm working
super hard on it I've honestly never had
more fun making a video as always thank
you so much for watching and if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck mine eyes